Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Let's get into a sleeve fight with Style Feet
Voice Sight.
The poodle haircut was created to help them
retrieve wild game hunted near water.
The bottom half was shaved to improve buoyancy
and let them move freely in water while hair
on the chest and joints was left untouched
to keep those areas warm.
The shaved face and top knot kept hair out
of the eyes and mouth and later in 18th century
France the nobility began fashioning poodle
hair into extravagant styles to match their
own ornate styles.
Dogs do in fact sweat - they just do it through
their feet.
When overheated dogs primarily cool down by
panting which allows moisture on the tongue
to evaporate and their fur is an insulator
- so most of a dog's sweat glands are around
its foot pads.
If they leave wet paw prints on the floor
after playing - it's probably sweat.
Dogs know what you're feeling because their
brains process emotion laden sounds similar
to humans.
Research has shown they respond to how we
say something instead of what we say.
Barking may have evolved from human training
- domesticated dogs have a complex system
of barks that humans can differentiate while
wild dogs bark infrequently or not at all.
Commonly thought to have monochrome vision
dogs actually do see in color.
Human eyes have three cones that detect color
while dogs only have two - leaving them with
the ability to distinguish between blue and
yellow but not green and red.
So a dog rainbow looks like this.
And we're left with Sleeve Fight.
During the Tang Dynasty in Ancient China tiny
pekingese dogs were bred to fit in the sleeves
of their master's silk robes.
They were used not only for warmth but also
as a hidden last line of defense against intruders.
And as always - thanks for watching.